cuando tomas cualquier curso de química
general cuando hablas de solubilidad
escucharás comúnmente la frase lo
semejante disuelve a los semejantes por
ejemplo un compuesto polar es soluble en
un solvente polar un ejemplo de un
compuesto polar podría ser algo como nhl
n
+ cl - el cloruro de sodio es un
compuesto iónico que es polar y es muy
soluble en agua el agua será nuestro
solvente polar aquí y entonces sabemos
que los semejante disuelve a lo
semejante el nhl se disolverá en nuestro
solvente polar h2o si piensas en un
compuesto no polar de acuerdo a nuestra
regla de solubilidad sabemos que
necesitaremos un solvente no polar el
componente no polar es soluble en un
solvente no polar pero si intentas tomar
un compuesto no polar pensemos en un
aceite
e intentas disolver ese aceite en un
solvente polar como el agua sabemos que
eso no funcionará sabemos que el aceite
no se disolverá en agua esto es un no
aunque la expresión los semejantes
disuelva a los semejantes podría estar
un poco sobre simplificada es muy útil
para predecir la solubilidad de
compuestos orgánicos veamos primero al
etanol aquí sabemos que el enlace entre
el oxígeno y el hidrógeno es un enlace
polarizado porque el oxígeno es más
electro negativo que el hidrógeno el
hidrógeno abandona un poco de densidad
electrónica el oxígeno tiene un poco más
de densidad electrónica alrededor de él
dándole una carga parcial negativa si el
oxígeno está quitando densidad
electrónica del hidrógeno el hidrógeno
se vuelve un poco positivo pierde un
poco de densidad electrónica este es un
enlace covalente polar entre el oxígeno
y el hidrógeno
esta es la porción polar de la molécula
de etanol si pensamos en la interacción
del etanol
con agua dibujaré una molécula de agua
tenemos dos pares libres de electrones
en el oxígeno sabemos que el agua es
polar el oxígeno es parcialmente
negativo los hidrógenos son parcialmente
positivos y entonces los enlaces de
hidrógeno entre nuestras dos moléculas
son factibles el hidrógeno parcialmente
positivo en el etanol es atraído al
oxígeno parcialmente negativo en el agua
así que tenemos fuerza de atracción
entre nuestras dos moléculas es una
fuerza inter molecular que llamamos
la se
d
pero
no
así que los enlaces de hidrógeno están
presentes en esta porción de la molécula
decimos que esta porción es hidrofílica
esta porción de la molécula ama el agua
pero si lee
significa que ama el agua qué pasa con
la otra porción esta porción aquí en la
izquierda de la molécula de etanol bueno
esto es ch2 y esto es ch3 por lo que
será no polar esta porción de la
molécula es no volar si es no polar no
le gusta para nada el agua de hecho le
tiene miedo al agua llamamos a esta la
porción y duro
soy
acá de la molécula hidrofóbica lo que
significa que le tiene miedo al agua
tenemos una pequeña región hidrofóbica
en nuestra molécula y tenemos una
porción hidrofílica de la molécula de
etanol y sabemos que el etanol es
soluble en agua es visible en toda
proporción el etanol se disolverá en
agua la porción hidrofílica de la
molécula supera a la porción hidrofóbica
el etanol se disolverá en agua
comparemos al etanol con el octano aquí
a la derecha el octanos tiene una
estructura muy similar al etanol tiene
un h por lo que son factibles los
enlaces de hidrógeno
esta es la porción hidrofílica de la
molécula de octano y por aquí de todos
los carbonos e hidrógenos que tenemos
aquí
esta es la porción hidrofóbica esta es
la porción hidrofóbica que sabemos que
es no polar
1 octanos no se disuelve en agua lo que
significa que la porción hidrofóbica
todo esto supera a la pequeña porción
hidrofílica de la molécula de octanos el
octanos será completamente no polar y si
quieres que se disuelva necesitarás un
solvente no polar porque un compuesto no
polar es soluble en un solvente no polar
y hay varios ejemplos de solventes
orgánicos que son no polares que
disolverán al 1 octanos veamos más
ejemplos luego tenemos sal sinama
aldehído este es el componente principal
del aceite de canela ya que dije aceite
podría sospechar que el sinam aldehído
no es soluble en agua si vemos esta
porción de la molécula de sinama leído
sabemos que el oxígeno es más electro
negativo que este carbono por lo que el
oxígeno obtendrá una carga parcial
negativa y este carbono de aquí obtendrá
una carga parcial positiva esta porción
es polar esta porción es hidrofílica y
será capaz de interactuar con agua pero
si miras esta porción de la molécula de
nuevo tenemos todos estos carbonos se
hidrógenos lo que significa que es
hidrofóbica y no polar en este caso la
porción hidrofóbica de la molécula de
sinama aldehído
a la porción hidrofílica pequeña y por
lo tanto el sinam ha leído es
hidrofóbico no se disuelve en agua si
quisieras disolver el sinam aldehído
necesitarías uno de los numerosos
solventes no polares de la química
orgánica los cuales podrías utilizar
para disolver alsina mal de ido ahora
veamos al ácido benzoico otra vez
tenemos esta porción de la molécula que
es hidrofílica pero esta porción de la
molécula es hidrofóbica si tomas algunos
cristales de ácido benzoico y los pones
en agua a temperatura ambiente esos
cristales no se disolverán muy bien del
todo el ácido benzoico no se disuelve en
agua a temperatura ambiente lo que
significa que la porción hidrofóbica
esta porción hidrofóbica supera a la
porción hidrofílica
pero qué pasa si añades una base a algo
como hidróxido de sodio una base tomará
el protón ácido en el ácido benzoico que
resulta ser este protón de aquí este es
el ácido y formarás benzoato de sodio
aquí a la derecha tenemos benzoato de
sodio el enea más vino del hidróxido de
sodio que añadimos y sid es protón amos
nuestro ácido benzoico piensa en lo que
le hicimos a la porción hidrofílica de
aquí
solo hicimos esto mucho mucho más volar
tenemos un enlace iónico ahora hicimos a
la porción hidrofílica mucho mucho más
polar y superamos esta porción
hidrofóbica
el benzoato de sodio es altamente
soluble en agua usaras este hecho en el
laboratorio de química orgánica si
tienes algo como ácido benzoico y
quieres disolver tus cristales en agua
puedes añadir algo de hidróxido de sodio
para formar benzoato de sodio y si
quieres volver a formar tu ácido
benzoico el benzoato de sodio es sólo la
base conjugada para el ácido benzoico
puedes solo protón ar
puedes solo protón ar este oxígeno de
aquí y convertir el benzoato de sodio
otra vez en ácido benzoico podrías usar
estas propiedades usar la química de
ácidos y bases para cambiar la
solubilidad y nuevamente esto lo usarás
mucho en el laboratorio